Abby and Ben did household
chores last weekend.
Together they earned $50.
That looks like an interesting
statement.
Let me underline that.
Together they earned $50 and
Abby earned $10 more than Ben.
So they also tell us--let me
underline that-- Abby earned
$10 more than Ben.
How much did each earn?
So that's the first question
that we have to answer.
Then they say, if you were to
use the graph above, and I put
it on the side here, which
strategy is most useful in
helping you find the answer
to the problem?
So there's kind of a meta-level
question of how do
we answer that first question.
Find the equation for
the blue line?
Red's y-intercept?
Find the points of
intersection?
Fair enough.
So let's just think about that
first question and then we can
answer this later, depending
on how we
answered that first question.
So that first statement,
together they earned $50.
What does that tell us?
Well, if we say that Abby's
earnings are represented by a,
and Ben's earnings are
represented by b, that tells
us that a plus b must be $50.
So a plus b have to
be equal to $50.
Abby's earnings plus Ben's
earnings are $50.
Together they earned $50.
That's all that statement
is telling us.
And if we see how they graphed
things here, on the vertical
axis, what we normally associate
with the y-axis,
they graphed Abby's earnings.
This is Abby's earnings
right there.
So we could say this
is the a-axis.
And then on the horizontal
axis, what we normally
associate with the x-axis,
they've charted Ben's
earnings, so we could say
that this is the b-axis.
So if we were to just map this
into the traditional
slope-intercept form, we don't
have x's and y's here.
We have b's and a's.
So we just want to express a
in terms of b, the vertical
variable in terms of the
horizontal variable.
That's just like the y equals
mx plus b form.
And the easiest way to do that
is just subtract b from both
sides of this equation.
And we get a is equal to
negative b plus 50.
So in this situation, you have
a slope of negative 1.
Let me write this down.
Slope of negative 1, that's
what's multiplying the
independent variable, and then
you have a y-intercept of 50,
or maybe we should say
an a-intercept.
But I'll write y-intercept
because that's what we're
familiar with.
You can view this as also like
the y or the vertical axis.
y-intercept of 50.
And you can see they
graphed that.
You have an a-intercept or
y-intercept of 50, and the
slope is negative 1.
If we move 20 in the positive
x-direction, we are moving
down 20, or we're going 20
in the negative vertical
direction, or in the negative
a-direction.
If we go 50 in the positive-- I
shouldn't say x-direction--
the positive b-direction, we go
down 50 in the a-direction,
so the slope is negative 1.
So this red line right here is
the graph that depicts this
first constraint.
It's important to realize that,
look, all this graph
shows is all the different
possible combinations of
Abby's and Ben's earnings
given only this first
constraint.
Maybe Abby made $50
and Ben earned $0.
Maybe Ben earned $50
and Abby earned $0.
Maybe they both earned $25.
Everything on this line would
be a valid combination of
Abby's and Ben's earnings given
the constraint that they
earned $50 combined.
Now, the second statement.
Abby earned $10 more than Ben.
So if we were to write that,
that's saying that Abby is
equal to Ben's earnings
plus $10.
Abby earned $10 more than Ben.
And here the slope is 1, you
see that right there.
There's an implicit 1
multiplying times this b.
And then the y-intercept
is 10.
And they graphed that here.
The y-intercept is 10
and the slope is 1.
You move 10 in the positive
b-direction, you move up 10 in
the positive a-direction.
So this blue line represents
all of the possible
combinations of Abby and Ben's
earnings if you only had this
constraint that Abby earned
$10 more than Ben.
If Ben earns $0,
Abby earns $10.
If Ben earns $10,
Abby earns $20.
If Ben earns $60,
Abby earns $70.
Now, we aren't dealing with only
the blue constraint or
only the red constraint.
We're dealing with
both of them.
We know that both of
them are true.
So whatever earnings Abby and
Ben made, they have to satisfy
both constraints or they have to
sit on both of these lines.
Now, what is the only point
that is sitting on both of
these lines?
Well, the only point that sits
on both lines is the
intersection of those lines.
That point right there is a
valid combination from the
point of view of the blue
constraint that Abby earned
$10 more than Ben.
And it's also a valid point or
a valid combination from the
point of view of the red
constraint that Abby and Ben
earned $50.
So that point represents Abby's
and Ben's earnings that
satisfy both constraints.
And we can eyeball
it right here.
It looks like Abby earned
$30 and Ben earned $20.
And that makes sense.
Combined, $20 plus $30 or $30
plus $20 is $50, so we meet
our first constraint.
And we see that Abby, $30, made
$10 more than Ben, who
only made $20.
So if you look at the point of
intersection, you will have
solved the problem.
Abby made $30, Ben earned $20.
So answering this second-- so
we know the answer-- so Abby
earned $30 and Ben earned $20.
Now, answering the second-level,
meta-level
question, which is the
best strategy?
We see, well, we had to find the
points of intersection, so
that is choice C.
We had to find the lines'
point of intersection.
Finding these other things
really wouldn't have helped us
solve the problem.